[Music]
chess
a game for kings and commoners
revolutionaries generals and their
soldiers scientists artists
merchants philosophers even computers
and artificial intelligence
a symbol of intellect
chess is a timeless example of strategic
superiority
those who play well are revered because
chess excellence cannot be purchased
it can only be earned
chess represents complete individual
power of mind
a venue for both creativity and
technical mastery
chess captures the zeitgeist of an era
and captivates our minds because chess
is much more than just a game
it is a reflection of life itself
chess is a reflection of us
[Music]
dating back to 6th century india
chaturanga is the earliest known form of
chess and more similarities to today's
game
variations of the game spread to the
sassanid empire or modern day iran where
they were taught to nobility
after hundreds of years these early
versions slowly converged into the
modern game we enjoyed today
chess traveled east to china where it
evolved into a game called xianji
the game also traveled west as islam
swept through arabia north africa and
the iberian peninsula
by the middle ages chess was being
played throughout europe
the game reached mongolia through silk
road routes and genghis khan spread
chess throughout the empire in the 1200s
as the european renaissance ushered in
an era of rebirth
chess became popular with the artists
scientists and religious leaders who
dominated renaissance culture
in fact
it was a catholic priest rui lopez de
segura who in 1561 published one of the
earliest and most influential books on
the game which documented the priest's
opening theories including his namesake
the rui lopez which is still a common
opening nearly 500 years later
the 18th century ushered in an era of
revolutions most notably on the american
continent
in france
and even in global industry
napoleon bonaparte was known to play
chess with his generals
benjamin franklin a founding father of
the united states was an avid chess
player who penned the essay
the morals of chess in 1786 where hero
life is a kind of chess
in which we have often points to game
and competitors or adversaries to
contend with
as the beginnings of globalization
shrank the world
chess evolved into a standardized game
for over a century one could not claim
dominance in the chess world without
first stepping in to the venerable cafe
de la regence in paris
it was here where musical composer and
infamous blindfold simultaneous player
andre filidor played against benjamin
franklin
the most notable of the players who
frequented the cafe was the american
paul murphy a child prodigy who stormed
the chess world
it's difficult to say who are the most
influential
chess
champions in history
in fact you have one player wasn't a
world champion who may have been just as
influential as any of the other greats
and that's paul morphy
after earning a law degree at the age of
20 but not being old enough to practice
law in new orleans
paul traveled to new york city where he
won the first american chess congress
and was recognized as the united states
chess champion
the following year murphy traveled to
the united kingdom and france where he
easily beat europe's best players
including german master adolf anderson
who attested that morphy was the
strongest player to ever play the game
widely regarded as the world's best
chess player paul morphy stunned the
chess world when he abruptly and
permanently left the game to begin his
life as a lawyer
morphy's death in 1884 left a hole in
the chess world that begged the question
who was the best player in the world
so morphy was way ahead of his time
and he ruled over his peers more than
any other world champion or best player
in the world
bobby fischer said morphy was the most
accurate player who ever lived
and he said he would beat any player
today
the style of play that characterizes
modern organized chess got its start in
1886 at the very first official world
chess championship
the match pit austrian-born american
wilhelm steinitz against his rival the
polish-born brit johannes zukertort
forever emblazoning these two players in
the history of the sport
wilhelm steinitz personally claimed to
be world champion from 1866 onward
paving the way for this universally
recognized inaugural event
his claim wasn't without merit
considering steinitz went on a historic
25 game winning streak between 1873 and
1882.
negotiations for the match were
contentious and lasted three years
before both sides finally agreed to the
terms
the match would take place over two
months
across three states with 20 games
scheduled
the first player to win 10 games
would be named the champion
steinitz for me is the
the first guy the
the guy who sat down and
wrote wrote the constitution you know
that kind of person
the sort of person you have at the start
of your country's history he for chess
he was the man who first put down these
famous rules and for many years we took
them
as the literal truth about how we start
off in chess
the championship match was also a battle
of theories that first played out in
print
from the end of the 1870s steinitz
published articles about his new
positional approach in the field
magazine
zukertort criticized steinitz's theory
in chess monthly magazine
the match was an opportunity to test out
their theory in practice
on january 11th the first round of play
began in new york city
zuckertort the editor of chess magazine
and a protege of steinitz started the
match strongly winning four of the first
five games a remarkable feat creating a
seemingly insurmountable lead
but steinitz was about to expose his
weakness
while much of the country was still
digging out of a blizzard in the plain
states steinitz needed to dig himself
out of a losing streak
the men headed to saint louis for the
next four games of the match steinitz
was a ferocious attacker in his youth
but had been practicing a new positional
style of play
it was a radical shift which he outlined
and defended in writing
positional play is the art of exploiting
small advantages to slowly improve one's
overall position rather than focusing on
short-term attacks
nearly a month to the day after the
first round began round two came to an
end steinitz scored three wins and a
draw
the final leg of the match took place in
new orleans momentum was on stein's side
and zukertor just couldn't keep up
he lost six of the last 11 games
the final score
12 and a half to seven and a half
wilhelm steinitz the first official
world chess champion was a titan on the
chessboard and brought a scientific i
think element to the game that really
set the tone for just how difficult
chess would be would be to play for many
years to come
in the years that followed steinitz
defended his chess theories by writing
extensively about them
he also used his insight to help the
american chess congress to define the
rules governing future world
championships
zukertord on the other hand struggled
with poor health following the
tournament
he died two years later at the age of
46.
an austrian chess sensation
steinitz had just moved to the u.s a few
years before the tournament it was only
fitting that an immigrant in the united
states won the world chess championship
in the same year the statue of liberty
was dedicated
steinitz would enjoy the success of the
world chess champion title for eight
years
in 1894
his undefeated match play would finally
come to an end
like his predecessor before him wilhelm
steinitz emmanuel lasker was also a very
scientific chess player a professor in
some ways in terms of his approach to
the game
one guy i
don't like to to leave out and he very
often is forgotten about is emmanuel
alaska
anybody who was world champion for 27
years
clearly could play chess
and
had an enormous influence on the the
game stynance and lasker were together i
think in changing a little bit of the
narrative of chess that it wasn't just
an art it is and it can be beautiful at
times but it also can be beautiful in
the fact that every lie is exposed on
the chessboard there is a best move and
having a style that finds it and
appreciates the principles of
controlling the center of development of
a a very scientific and methodical
theoretical approach to the game was
sort of was sort of cemented by steinis
and lasker in their approach to chess in
that era
the young 25 year old lasker urged the
seasoned 58 year old to face him in the
world chess championship before calling
it quits
lasker wanted each side to stake five
thousand dollars but found it
challenging to raise the funds
steinitz agreed to reduce the stakes to
two thousand dollars each which was less
money than earlier championships but
still a sizable pool at that time
while many praised steinitz for agreeing
to the reduction
some have theorized that he desperately
needed the money
both players also mutually agreed that
the copyright to publish each game's
moves was owned by the players
marking an early and important
discussion on intellectual property
rights in chess
the championship would take place in
three locations in the spring of 1894.
new york city hosted the first eight
games
philadelphia would host games nine
through eleven
followed by games 12 through 19 in
montreal canada
the first player to win 10 games would
be declared the winner
great competitors can't resist the
challenge
and steinitz declared he would win
without a doubt
lasker had other plans the world chess
championship of 1894 started off a
well-balanced match
the score was tied after six games
marked by lasker's use of the rui lopez
opening
lasker then took a commanding lead with
five straight victories as the match
transitioned from new york to
philadelphia
steinitz briefly looked like he might
bounce back in montreal
but the young lasker was not to be
denied
the players traded wins until lasker
ultimately won the championship in the
19th game
when he won against stanis i know that
stainless steel up and he
he shouted three times hooray for the
new world champion
so
it was a very
very gentleman way of
surrendering the crown
unlike steinitz who stuck to his
strategy of positional play
lasker had a more flexible approach
changing his style from game to game
there were newspaper reports of steinitz
playing poorly while suffering from
insomnia during part of the match
details are limited but the 16th game
was played in private in a small room at
montreal's venerable cosmopolitan club
attended only by the players and match
officials
regardless emmanuel lasker was the new
world chess champion
fans would talk about the games for
years
other chess players would emulate
lasker's style
and future generations would study his
games in books
videos and articles
for me laska was the ultimate
pragmatist the ultimate
practical chess player he actually knew
how to pinpoint his opponent's
weaknesses and take advantage so the
first practical player
the rematch would be the first time
lasker had to defend his title
this time
in moscow
this time around he beat steinitz in an
utterly dominant fashion
lasker won seven of the first 11 games
the other four were ties
steinitz won games 12 and 13.
after which lasker won three of the last
four games to retain the title
in a published letter to the press
steinitz cited a multitude of issues
surrounding his accommodations in moscow
including overheated rooms the lack of
fresh air and the unavailability of cold
water and ice
however
steinitz also claimed in response to the
question
why am i beaten so badly
he writes
that lasker
was the greatest player i have ever met
perhaps
the greatest that ever lived
fast forward to 1907.
lasker was studying for his doctorate in
mathematics and thus had little time to
practice chess his challenger was frank
marshall from the united states his home
would eventually become the famous
marshall chess club in new york city
despite lasker's studies he crushed
marshall and held him winless throughout
the competition with games in new york
philadelphia washington dc baltimore
chicago and memphis
it was a battle marked by lasker's
employment of the queen's gambit and
marshall's use of the french defense
marshall in his mercurial style would
note that tedious play
aimed at wearing down my opponent is
averse to my nature
lasker had no such reservations
lasker won the first three games
then scored one win and seven draws in
games four through eleven
before winning the last four games for a
final score of 8-0
with seven draws
a year later lasker would defend his
title a third time
this time in dusseldorf and munich
against fellow german siebert terrace
one of the most influential chess
theoreticians
and popular writers of the late 19th
and early 20th centuries
game 14 in the match was a nail biter
with 119 moves it held the record for
the longest game in a world championship
for years
ultimately lasker easily held on to his
reign beating terrash eight to three
with five draws
the match against darish was
conceptually very difficult match
[Music]
so the fighter was playing the
theoretician if we can put it this way
and it could have been a different turn
of the events and the different turn of
the chess history had to hit that
respondus
in 1910
lasker defended his title twice
first in a controversial match that
ended in a tie with austro-hungarian
chess master carl schlechter a strong
but sometimes unambitious master
the players agreed to a best of 10 match
with five games in vienna and berlin
respectively
the shortened match was the result of
london st petersburg and stockholm all
failing to participate in raising stakes
for an even longer match
unlike lasker's earlier title wins this
championship was dramatic and well
played by both players
in fact eight of the ten games were
draws
schlecter won game five
the next four games were also draws
in the tenth and final game of the
championship
lasker had to win in order to tie the
match and retain his title
in a letter to the new york evening post
lasker wrote
the match with schlechter is nearing its
end
and it appears probable that for the
first time in my life
i shall be the loser
if that should happen
a good man will have won the world
championship
however lasker came back to win the 10th
game and retained his title later that
year lasker was challenged by
russian-born frenchman david yanovsky
the entire match was held in berlin
and in terms of the score
lasker beat janovsky
in the most one-sided world championship
match in history
the final score was 8-0 with three draws
emmanuel alaska was world champion for
27 years i mean the name lasker must
have been known by intelligent people
and knowledgeable people cultivated
people in general even if they knew
little about chess
a true sportsman
chess wasn't the only game that lasker
was interested in he was a first class
bridge player
and invented a game called laska
which is similar to checkers
but it's his role as a ferocious
defender
and a pioneer of chess strategy and
psychology that made him a star emmanuel
lasker successfully defended his world
championship title five times
will anyone beat laska's record of
standing on the chest from for 27 years
honestly i don't think so
he's really the first universal player
so again he was equally good in
everything but above all he was a
fighter
war puts a lot of things on hold
families
plans
and on occasion the world chess
championship
but that's not the strangest part of
jose raul capablanca's rise to fame
capoblanca was a personable cuban chess
prodigy who could play chess before he
could read he had been winning
tournaments since he was 13 years old
by the time he was 22 capoblanca played
with great intuition and fluidity but
his true object of attention was the end
game
he was ready to compete for the world
title challenging world chess champion
emmanuel asker
that was in 1911.
the problem was the two players couldn't
agree on the format lasker was unwilling
to play the traditional first to win 10
games method
the arguing grew so intense that the men
stopped speaking to each other a few
years later they reconciled at the 1914
saint petersburg chess tournament
they finally agreed to terms for a
championship match lasker came from
behind to win that event in may
and then only a few weeks later gavrilo
princip would assassinate the archduke
franz ferdinand world war one had begun
it was reported that emanuel lasker lost
his entire fortune in germany during the
war and was even detained for a short
period there would be no world chess
championship for another seven years
in 1920 negotiations between lasker and
cappablanca resumed
mainly through several correspondences
chess critics in london criticized both
men so harshly that it became a strain
on their friendship
lasker resigned his title in the dispute
over match conditions and named cappa
blanca his successor but capablanca
stated i would much prefer to play for
the title regardless of the outcome of
the match the chess world agreed and
didn't accept lasker's gesture despite
lasker declining in health
eventually the two players agreed to
play in havana cuba for the 1921 world
chess championship
the format was best of 24
the first man to win 12 and a half
points or eight games would be declared
the winner
cappa blanca had been undefeated in
chess competition for five years running
by the time the match would start
the match was marked by both players
competing theories of the queen's gambit
decline
the difference in age and sharpness of
tactical ideas would prove to be
capablanca's advantage
but the championship ended strangely
lasker resigned from the match after 14
games citing poor health as the reason
despite resigning the match
lasker stated he was convinced he could
not have beaten his opponent
capoblanca was officially the new world
chess champion
capablanca was a reflection of all of
his predecessors in terms of being
aggressive being creative being a genius
as some would call him but also being so
technically sound that he would be
willing to take games into the end game
and win with just the smallest of
advantages our first
proper certified bon viva
he
he loved the good life
stories about mistresses about romances
about
wearing fine suits and
going in fifth avenue you know all that
stuff and
he was um
[Music]
i think the first world champion who
really properly enjoyed himself
kappa blanca wrote of chess in his book
leziones elementalists
chess serves like few other things in
this world
to distract
and momentarily forget the worries of
daily life
capoblanca would not have to defend his
title for six years
it was september 1927 in buenos aires
capoblanca was the huge favorite
he had already beaten russian player
alexander aliakin in other tournaments
and not lost a single game to him
but alecan was no stranger to the game
or the pressure that comes with it
born into a wealthy russian family his
older brother taught him to play chess
by age 16 he was considered one of
russia's top players
alekhin's preparation checklist was
complete he had raised the required ten
thousand dollars for the match he had
studied kappa blanca's games and learned
to play in his style for this match
even physically trained for the
competition
all that was left was to play
and preparation showed
the meeting between capablanca and
alecan was one of the longest formal
world chess matches in history
and though alaiken won
he later admitted that even he was
surprised by the victory
it was the first of many matches to come
for the world championship that would be
won by players who had never before
defeated their opponent alexander alikin
as is appropriate for someone who
follows capablanca was the tormented one
he
he never seemed to find peace in his
life even when i watch his games you
feel his pain somehow
during the course of the match a decree
granting alien's request to be a french
citizen was granted
he started the match as a russian
and would win the championship as a
frenchman
the two masters made an informal
agreement to play a rematch sometime
within the next year but it would never
happen because kappablanca failed to
raise the necessary ten thousand dollars
yephim bogali above a russian-born
german player then challenged aliyekin
calling boggly above a more serious
challenger al-jajen accepted despite
bogali above's failure to raise ten
thousand dollars
the two agreed to a public match held in
six different cities in germany and the
netherlands with haleekan receiving six
thousand dollars
regardless of the match's outcome and
his challenger receiving the balance of
the monies raised for the match
bogali above had beaten past world
champions emmanuel alaska and jose
capoblanca but he could not beat the
reigning champ
it would be five more years
before alejan would have to defend his
title again by facing bogali above for a
second time
not only was the challenger the same but
so was the agreed upon format
it was the only championship ever held
inside nazi germany
many players before him could be boxed
in or defined by a style or an approach
you could not box in alexander alekhine
his truly well-rounded approach to the
game showed that the future best chess
players in the world could not deny or
neglect any skills that they would need
to develop to be the best alexander
alekhine is maybe the first true super
grand master that existed
in those days there was no strict
qualification process to challenge the
title holder
ayeken's choice for an opponent was
conservative by most standards the world
was suffering under a cloud of the great
depression
tensions were high as germany began to
rearm and mussolini's italy attacked
ethiopia
the world chess championship held in
multiple cities and towns across the
netherlands offered a distraction of the
time
in fact in one newspaper the match was
positioned as bigger news than the
situation in ethiopia
dutch chess player max ova was
considered by his peers to be a
consistent player solid but not
extraordinary
ova had won a world amateur championship
but mostly only played tournaments when
it did not clash with his math teaching
duties
throughout his life over refused to call
himself a professional chess player
whether it was overconfidence or simply
underestimating his opponent
attacking's seemingly safe choice wasn't
a safe bet after all
ova won the title by overcoming a
three-point deficit as late as the ninth
game at the end of 30 games elva beat
the champ by just one point
this is also a
bit of a paradox he was the amateur he
was the real amateur but in some aspects
he was
more professional than the professional
chess players he taught the
professionals of his time
how to work on their openings
professionally and he also taught the
professionals of his time to work on
their physical condition and that's
probably one big lesson that alekhine
learned from him and why he came back in
the second match in a better physical
condition
al-jacin would get a chance to redeem
himself and he did two years later with
a record-setting win making him the very
first player in chess history to regain
the title after losing it but he
wouldn't live to face another challenger
he died shortly after world war ii
before another match could take place
making the 1937 world chess championship
the last event where the champion had
control of the title and could set match
conditions
world war ii sidelined the championship
for 10 years
and after aliens death in 1946 for the
first time since 1886 no reigning
champion existed
his death created a gap between reigns
of world champions
the international chess federation
commonly referred to by its french
acronym fide or the federation
international
seized the moment
it would take control of the next world
chess championship
their solution was a tournament
featuring a quintuple round robin of top
players to determine the best player in
the world the roster was a who's who in
the chess world
the soviet union's mikhail bhattvinik
was a favorite leading into the
competition paul cares another ussr
player in his early 30s was already a
veteran of international play an
accountant by day
samuel rushevsky was a polish-american
grandmaster and eight-time u.s chess
champion another participant was 1935
world champion max ova who had not been
playing well in recent years
rounding out the five was vasily smizlov
a rising star and already a strong
player who had emerged during world war
ii
he had not played in the avro tournament
which was considered the most important
chess event in 1938 but the soviet union
was allowed to substitute him as a
competitor in place of sallow floor
finally three years after the war ended
it was time for the tournament to take
place
matches were set for the hague and
moscow
travel restrictions were still in place
in much of the soviet union
the soviets installation of communist
leaning governments in eastern europe
spurred american and british fears that
communism would spread worldwide
the tournament got underway as planned
mikhail badvinick had plus scores
against all of the players in the round
robin style tournament
and became the sixth world chess
champion winning the tournament
convincingly
in subsequent years he tied two matches
to retain his title
he also lost and regained the title
twice
but vinik also helped to pioneer
computer chess in the years to come
but vinix victory marked the beginning
of the era of soviet domination of
international chess
an era that would last over 20 years
mikhail bought vinix impact and
influence over the game throughout
eastern europe and throughout the former
soviet union is greater than nobody
before or after him chess was huge in
soviet union uh it was an everyday life
people played uh chess in their spare
time
it was very common to follow tournaments
and matches and especially in 1950s
1960s it was one of the biggest sports
out there michelle bought vinnick the
father of the soviet chess union the man
who would set the tone for generations
to come and help the soviet union rise
to world dominance not just because of
his dominance as a world chess champion
but because of his influence over the
chess culture he also had like this
almost like a rock star status for the
best chess players
um but i think the foundation of that
was like they were literally millions of
people who play chess as you know like
as a hobby
in the stalin years
catch-up and overtake was a central
theme in the soviet ethos by the time
mikhail bhatvinik won the 1948 world
chess championship the soviets had done
more than catch up to the world's best
players they could overtake them in
nearly any match
but vinik's first opportunity to defend
the world title he won in 1948
came in 1951
in the first match played under the
supervision of fide
his challenger
david bronstein was the first chosen
through a new qualifying system based on
inter zonal and candidates tournaments
this selection method remained in place
until 1993.
[Music]
if brunchdain's name sounds familiar
it's because his book
zurich international chess tournament
is widely considered one of the greatest
chess books ever written grand master
bronzedin described by his peers as a
creative genius and master of tactics
appeared to be a strong opponent
the men battled game by game
the match ended in a 12-12 tie
according to the rules that's all
badvinick needed to retain the title of
world champion
but vinik held on to the title against
challenger vasily smislov in the same
fashion at the 1954 world chess
championship in moscow
harry golembeck the author of the book
world chess championship 1954 classified
the style of smithslav in this manner
rich originality in the openings
imaginative strategy in the middle game
and above all an immense virtuosity as
an endgame player in this last
department he is probably the strongest
player in the world
as for botvinnik
golembeck writes
other players may have a wider knowledge
of the openings some few may have and
even more impeccable technique but no
one has the equivalent strength of mind
and willpower
again but vinik retained his status as
world champion but but vinik and
smizlov's rivalry was only beginning
the 1957 world chess championship was a
rematch of the 1954 fight against
smislov
this time but vinik decided not to use a
second in the match
a second essentially assists the player
by helping prepare openings and studying
the opponent's games the move came after
but vinik feared that his second had
leaked information in the 1954 match
against smislov
unwilling to trust anyone else he went
at it alone
but
it was a decision that might have cost
him
after 22 of 24 games the score was 12
and a half to nine and a half in
smizlov's favor the margin did not
change with two draws in the remaining
games and thus but vinik had to hand
over the title to smizlov
fide rules at the time allowed bought
vinegar rematch this time a year later
he came ready to win
in the third match between these
opponents botvinnik won the first three
games it was an early lead that smizlov
could not overcome
but vinik was back on top
but vinik was
one of the first
pioneers of scientific chess of method
of preparation
but really method is probably the most
important word
he was also special because he was able
to discover new ways of playing with
black for victory from move one
to fully appreciate the 1960 world chess
championship between defending champion
mikhail badwinik
and challenger mikhail tao
you have to know what happened
12 years earlier
but vinik had just won the 1948
tournament he celebrated with a vacation
in riga latvia while there
an eleven-year-old boy paid him a visit
hoping to play a game against the new
champion but vinnie's wife told the boy
the champ was asleep
the boy was michael tall
in all the years that followed
the two had never faced each other
before the title match began in 1960
tao won the opportunity to play
botvinnik by beating players such as
paul kerres tigran petrossian and a
16-year-old bobby fisher
the youngest player to ever win the ussr
championship
some called him a creative genius
surprise attacks and confusing moves
seemed to be tal's strategy
this earned him the nickname the wizard
of riga
before it was even over
one newspaper article with the headline
russian champ losing title to smashing
surprise tactics claimed tau was using
psychological warfare against botvinnik
the match ended after only 21 games
obviously tyler was the the most gifted
tactician
and
magician of chess so he is famous for
that obviously he completely appended
the game so he showed that you can win
at the highest level with this style
that nobody thought possible before he
changed game images much more dynamic
tal was declared the new world chess
champion by four points
but
he wouldn't hold the title for long
a year later tal and budvinic met in a
rematch
tao who suffered from kidney problems
exacerbated by his drinking and smoking
was reportedly advised by his doctors
that he should postpone the match
but vinik agreed
only if doctors certified him unfit
tal went ahead with the match
the great bodvinik had studied tal's
style and was now more prepared for the
1961 world chess championship he beat
tao by a margin of 13 to eight and
regained his title this man with iron
will and iron discipline who lost
many many world championship matches but
always went back studied his weaknesses
fixed his problems came back and won the
next match
a year later
towel was operated on and the severity
of his kidney disease was revealed
but vinix next challenger was soviet
armenian grandmaster tigran
petrosian's victory at the 1962
candidates tournament which earned him
the right to challenge botvinnik came
with controversy american bobby fischer
accused the soviets of collusion
he claimed petrosian and others arranged
match draws to prevent fisher from
winning
though nothing was proven
fide adjusted the rules and format for
subsequent events
iron to gran as he was called prepared
for the 1963 world championship in a
most unusual way
in addition to practicing chess
petrosians spent several hours a day
skiing
he believed that physical fitness would
make the difference in long matches
petran is probably the most
unusual world championship and most
difficult to describe
he had a very special style
he was had enormous sense of danger
that allowed him to uh defend positions
that are probably wouldn't be tenable
for other grand masters and also for
preventing the
uh attacks before they even like
commenced
um
that probably was the thing that was
most special about petrossan
the match
which would be the last for bot vinnick
ended with a score of five to two with
15 draws
petrosian would become the ninth world
chess champion
but vinik who did not have the automatic
right for a rematch this time
did not re-enter the world championship
cycle and would eventually retire from
competitive play in 1970.
he is still called the patriarch of
soviet chess for becoming the first
soviet grand master and spending a lot
of time coaching young players in later
years
but vinik died of pancreatic cancer in
1995 one of the critical players in the
soviet era of chess supremacy
botwennick
was universally acknowledged by the
soviets as the patriarch the the man who
did it who brought the title back he
brought the title back to mother russia
and it stayed in mother russia for a
long time
boris spassky was another giant of
soviet chess
his start with chess began during the
infamous siege of leningrad in world war
ii
he played his first game of chess on the
train as his family evacuated
spassky was highly coached for
competition throughout his early years
he was described as a universal player
equally adept at attack
and defense at any stage of the game
his skills would be put to the test at
the 1966 world chess championship
against reigning champ tigran petrossian
the format for the title match was once
again best of 24 games
with the champion retaining the title in
the event of a 12-12 tie
after game 22 of the match the score was
12 to 10
and petrosian retained the title by
default
a few years later spassky would get
another shot
in 1969 the two men met for a rematch
as spassky had again won the candidates
tournament
with the title of world chess champion
on the line once more
it went down to 23 games
this time spassky won the traditional
thing to say about spasky is that he was
the universal player so he was able to
do a little bit of everything at the
highest level people said that
spassky was very difficult to play
because he could be a chameleon he could
be a plain style on any day so i think
that was
his biggest uh
talent uh when he was becoming a world
champion so fishes spassky i remember it
very
very clearly yes
fisher had crushed the competition on
the way to becoming the challenger he
outplayed grandmaster's mark taimanov
and bent larson beating each by a
perfect score of six to zero
a feat no one else had ever accomplished
in any candidate's event
after that he eliminated former world
champion tigaron petrosian six and a
half to two and a half to qualify for
the biggest challenge of his life the
1972 world chess championship match
between fisher and spassky
was probably the greatest spectacle in
the history of chess it was front page
news every day
it was on evening television coverage
the news there it was all over the place
i think that was the golden age of
soviet chess and maybe just in general
it was perceived as
a clash between
ideologies you know democracy and
dictatorship the soviet megalithic
system
versus uh raw boned american
individualism
uh as uh expressed by fischer
but actually it was just a match between
the two best chess players in the world
the championship in reykjavik iceland
was billed as the match of the century
it was the first time in 24 years the
world chess championship was played
outside the ussr you couldn't walk into
a bar without
people watching
these five-hour games on every other day
it was a very big thing
fisher's pre-match demands should have
been an indicator of what was to come
the american grand master demanded more
prize money a larger cut of the movie
rights and he insisted that the match
chessboard be remade as a staunton chess
set from jacques of london
there were moments when it looked like
the match wasn't going to happen at all
fisher failed to make it to the opening
ceremony
after a two-day delay a british
investment banker upped the prize fund
henry kissinger national security
advisor for then-president richard nixon
reportedly called fisher and said
america wants you to go over there and
beat the russians
fisher eventually landed in reykjavik
mere hours before forfeiting the match
and finally the match got underway
it was a nail biter from start to finish
both in and out of gameplay
fisher didn't show up for the start of
game one
spassky made his move
and waited
nine minutes passed before fischer
arrived
spassky won the first game after his
opponent had played a bishop move that
looked like a rookie mistake
fisher blamed the tv cameras for the
loss and demanded they be removed for
the second game
organizers refused fisher responded by
forfeiting the game
handing spassky another win in the match
spassky deserves huge credit for saving
the match by agreeing to play the third
game out of the view of spectators
game four was a compromise
player resumed back on the main stage in
front of spectators but without tv
cameras
the game ended in a draw
fischer's behavior and demeanor
seemed to suggest he was not prepared to
compete
but out of nowhere he took command of
the match
winning games five six and eight
the final score after 21 games was 12
and a half to eight and a half
bobby fischer was the new world champion
it was an embarrassing loss to the
soviet chess dynasty
fischer became the first american to win
the competition since 1894. the victory
also interrupted 24 years of soviet
domination it's basky it's actually a
tragedy in it in a way that the guy is
best known for losing a match
and
he did so much more than this in his
chess career but you know i mean it's
just
you know it's sometimes your fate
in life to be known for
a defeat
rather than
you know all the many many victories
that you
you've had over those years fisher was
an instant global celebrity he returned
to his home in new york where he
celebrated an official day in his honor
the einstein of chess as he was called
appeared on the cover of sports
illustrated and made several appearances
on television
then
in a dramatic fashion
fisher gave up the title of world chess
champion
it was 1975.
fisher wanted the rematch format to go
back to the same format used in the
first world championship complaining the
current format leads players to opt for
a draw instead of going for the win fide
accepted all his demands except for one
fischer wanted to keep his title in the
event of a 9-9 score
when the two sides could not come to
terms
fisher forfeited his title
anatoly karpov won the title from fisher
without having to play him but that
should take nothing away from just how
great he was anatoly karpov would be one
of the hardest nuts to crack of any
world chess champion in history he was
also someone who showed just how much
you could win not just by executing on
your own plans but by stopping your
opponent's plan
as for bobby fischer he lived a secluded
life for two decades before he and boris
baskey would meet again in an unofficial
rematch in 1992
the only catch was that the match was
held in yugoslavia which was under a
united nations embargo at the time
fischer went ahead with the match
despite a warning from the united states
government that his participation would
have consequences
u.s authorities issued a warrant for
fisher's arrest
fischer never returned to the united
states and died in iceland in 2008.
bobby fisher burned
brighter than anybody else
you know when he was hot
he was
absolutely on fire all the great players
who came after bobby fischer were
inspired by him even if they now put
down his play and
possibly detract from it a little bit he
was really something he really changed
the game of chess put a new face on it
defending champion russian anatoly
karbov had a lot to prove after fide
declared him the new champion upon bobby
fischer's forfeiture of the title
karpov's challenger in the 1978 fight
was victor
one of the soviet union's top grand
masters until he defected to the west in
1976.
the competitors argued over the smallest
details
when courtship indicated he wanted to
bring his own chair to the event karpov
requested that it be examined the men
also argued over the flags on the
player's table after which the decision
was made not to use any player flags at
all
then there were the sunglasses
cautionary wore reflective glasses
complaining that karpov and his team
which included a well-known hypnotist
were staring at him
karpov said the light reflected in the
sunglasses bothered his
eyes at one point in the tournament
karpov's team sent blueberry yogurt
the korchnoy team accused the soviets of
using the yogurt as some kind of code
by game eight tensions were so high that
karpov refused to shake korchnoy's hand
karpov was on the brink of victory with
a five to two lead
but
korchnoy fought back to tie the match
all the arguing political maneuvering
and psychological warfare culminated in
the next game karpov won
and retained his world title
courchnoy would challenge karpov a
second time
this time in murano italy in 1981 this
time korchjoy had no time for drama he
was still trying to get his wife and son
out of the soviet union
which seemed to distract him from the
match
in the rematch it took karpov just 18
games to secure the title earning the
match the nickname the massacre in
murano
people have forgotten how strong karpa
was and i think
his legacy
is
i don't know if it's tarnished but
it's easily forgotten and the beginning
of the um the 1984 match
was one of the most impressive displays
of
of chess ever seen
the tournament pitted defending champion
anatoly karpov
against challenger
21 year old gaddy kasparov who had won
the candidates tournament gary casper
was the opposite of coppo in many ways
he
his style is very different
but they were both products of the
soviet school of chess they were both
products of both phoenix school they
both
knew how the system worked kasparov
was
a loud-mouthed
[Music]
troublemaker
seen as kind of western
and
he was
[Music]
i think
perceived as the coming of perestroika
and glasnost which was just beginning to
become a
you know a talking point
the 1984 match started off in september
and karpov was off to a solid start
after nine games he needed only two more
wins to be the first to win six games
and retain the title
but kasparov wasn't going down without a
fight
17 draws followed
finally at game 32
kasparov won a game against the reigning
champ
by game 47 kasparov was gaining ground
but both men were showing signs of
exhaustion officials were concerned
about the strain on the player's health
the men wanted to continue but in a
controversial move the president of the
world chess federation ended the match
nearly five months from the day it
started
the men would meet again seven months
later in a new world championship
many considered it a restart of the
abandoned match
this time the tournament would be played
as the best of 24 games to prevent
another lengthy seemingly endless battle
the men traded wins and draws in the
first several games as the match wore on
and the draws piled up
both men felt the psychological pressure
to push for a decisive victory after
game 15 the match was still tied then
came game 16 and what some would call
kasparov's masterpiece
it was a sicilian paulson
the first 10 moves of the game were
identical to those from game 12. karpov
was the first to deviate 34 moves later
karpov was forced to sacrifice his queen
kasparov took the lead the 1985 world
chess championship came down to the last
game it was a must win for karbal
karpov resigned on move 42
kasparov would defend his title three
more times against karpov once in 1987
and again
in 1990 both matches were incredibly
close with kasparov narrowly winning
i was 15 years old when kappa
and gasparo played their first world
championship match
and i was 21 years old and they had
still not finished playing each other
they
had one of these remarkable rivalries
and by matches which dwarf the lengths
of modern matches
growing up and watching kasparov
dominate the chess world is is something
i i still remember vividly because of
course for every young chess player i
don't think there was a single one on
the planet who didn't idolize
everything that he was gary's two years
older than me
honestly speaking there is a difference
in class
and um
[Music]
you know i'm
a good player at my best i was a very
good player
but
he was on a level
higher than that
[Music]
in 1993 nigel short won the candidates
tournament putting him in a position to
challenge gary kasparov for the world
chess championship
at that time the final was decided by
the reigning champion the challenger and
fide but when fide announced manchester
as the venue without consulting kasparov
and short the men cut their ties to the
organization
you know for me this whole thing was
done on a point of principle and
it was
deep deep
dissatisfaction
with the way
the
proceedings were conducted
kasparov and short formed the
professional chess association in
retaliation to the feed a decision and
set about playing the world chess
championship under its terms
the match took place at the savoy
theater in london where kasparov won
handling 12 and a half to seven and a
half becoming the first pca world chess
champ
fide wasn't backing down it stripped
kasparov of his previous world chess
title and held its own version of the
world championship between the next
highest ranking players in the
candidates tournament anatoly karpov and
yantima competed in fide's 1993 title
match karpov won
for the first time we had two world
chess champions
one thing i can say about playing
kasparov is the
the level of in
the intensity of playing the world
championship final
it was an immense strain
in the full public view
loads of
publicity
um
it was hard and it took me a while to
get used to it
[Music]
in the 14th century the western schism
resulted in two different men claiming
to be the true pope
the rise of different boxing
associations in the 1960s resulted in
the use of the term undisputed to
determine the true boxing champ
by the 1990s the chess world would
experience its own power struggle
kasparov was declared the pca world
champ again in 1995
in 1996 and 1998 anatoly karpov beat
gotakomsky and viswanathan anand
respectively for the fide title
fide actually tried to unify the rival
titles by breaking with tradition and
proposing a new knockout style
tournament that had been used in lower
level matches the plan was to seed feed
a champion anatoly karpov and pca
champion gary kasparov directly into the
semi-finals
but kasparov didn't want to defend his
title under those circumstances and
declined his invitation
so karpov was given a spot in the final
instead
he beat veswanathanan in a match played
in switzerland
fide used the single elimination format
for the next few years despite the
controversy surrounding the new
structure
critics of the format said the short
matches and rapid playoff style left too
much to chance and didn't ensure that
the best player would win
others like the fact that more players
could be included and thought it made
scheduling easier since only one venue
was needed
under this format alexander califman
became the fide world champion in 1999
beating vladimir kopian in las vegas
in 2000
both the pca
and fide organized championships on the
pca side russian player vladimir kramnik
ended casparo's reign in a close match
played in london there was a turning of
the page i guess in welcoming kramnik as
um
as his successor in the same year rising
indian star vishwanathan anand earned
the fide world title after beating
alexei shirov in a match played in india
and iran
only fide organized the championship in
2002. ukrainian player ruslan ponomariov
won the single elimination event held in
moscow and in 2004
kremnick defended his title in a match
that ended 2-2 with 10 draws
a draw was not enough for hungarian
peter leica to unseat kramnik
in the feed a championship of 2004
rustam kasim jhanov beat michael adams
fire eventually abandoned the single
elimination format
in 2005 the governing organization
decided to use normal time controls
returning the matches to a much slower
pace
eight top players were named in a double
round robin
in the end veselyn topalov was declared
the 2005 feed a winner besting
vishwanathan
and peter svidler who tied for second
the title had been split for 13 years
and it was time to unite the chess world
and produce an undisputed world champion
the world chess championship of 2006 was
the unifying match between the pca's
classical world chess champion vladimir
kramnik and fite world chess champion
veselyn topalov vladimir kramnik
defeated topalov
after that fidei regained control of the
world chess championship and the match
reverted to being based on a final match
between the defending champion and a
challenger decided by the candidate's
tournament
what impresses me most about kramnik as
a player i guess he he's one of the most
accurate players in history that i think
doesn't get enough credit for the fact
that
like like the next generation coming
after kasparov and we talked about the
fact that kasparov welcomed the machines
kramnik was using machines to influence
his style of play i think earlier than
people realized he's one of the deepest
thinkers in
strategy and openings in jazz
in fact given that he had much less help
than many others his impact is even
greater he has this
ability i think to teach and explain
chess that's unique
vishwanathan anand is a five-time world
chess champion
born in india in 1969 anand learned to
play chess from his mother when he was
six by the time he was 14 he was winning
tournaments like the asian junior
championship
national chess championship and the
world junior chess championship
all on his way to becoming india's first
grand master at age 18.
anan has been one of the most
well-regarded figures in the chess world
for two decades
earning the respect of chess rivals and
champions alike
i must say that i admire wishy a lot
because i think
he was one of the uh
world champions probably the only world
champion who won uh world champion
titles in every single format with every
single time control with every single
system that existed matches knockout i
mean
and he never
well in my
memory at least he never complained
he won his first world champion title in
2000 in a 100 player single elimination
tournament in new delhi india and tehran
backed by home crowd support anand moved
to the early rounds with little trouble
his momentum stalled in the
quarterfinals with a streak of draws but
it was enough to keep advancing the
final match pitted anand against alexei
shiroff anand won the coveted title
going undefeated in the tournament with
eight wins and 12 draws
the win made anand the first world
champion from asia and the first world
champion from outside the former soviet
union since bobby fisher
anand received a 528 thousand dollar
cash prize for winning the fide world
title to talk about vishwanathan anan's
achievements in chess and what he
represents to the game becoming
truly global is is hard to put into
words i think people forget that
before vichy anand
every world chess champion other than
robert james fisher was of former soviet
state union descent in some way 2007
marked the beginning of four straight
world title wins for anand
in mexico city anand beat vladimir
kramnik and boris gelfand in a double
round robin tournament if you win a
world title you should be able to say i
am the vultures champion and finish your
sentence so to speak
so when i won the world title in 2007
in mexico city
it had been reunified for
just under a year at that point
and i felt one big weight off my
shoulders
this feeling that i had to explain my
title had almost disappeared in 2008
anand again defeated vladimir kramnik in
a best of 12 match
then in 2010 he narrowly defeated vessel
and toppolov
three wins two losses and seven draws
the 2010 world chess championship was
not only a testament to anan's fortitude
but also to a stellar reputation anan's
flight to the championship game in sofia
bulgaria was originally cancelled due to
a volcanic eruption in iceland
when the bulgarian organizers refused to
delay the games
anand traveled 40 hours by car to get
there and if that wasn't a rough enough
start anand lost the first game to
topalov in just 30 moves
but the reigning champ didn't back down
after 11 games the score was tied five
and a half to five and a half
anan signaled his willingness to accept
the draw in game 12.
paulov didn't want to take his chances
against anand in a forced rapid playoff
given anand's reputation as a formidable
rapid player but topalov couldn't
convert the game to a win
anand retained his world champion title
by one point
after the tournament anand revealed that
former rivals gary kasparov vladimir
kramnik and even magnus carlson helped
him prepare for the 2010 world chess
championship
anan's regard as a good sportsman was
evident when indian prime minister
manmohan singh invited him to a dinner
he was hosting for us president barack
obama in november of 2010
anand was the only sports person
invited finally in 2012 anand would win
the world champion title just one more
time beating boris gelfon in moscow
to say the statement
with where we are now for india that
vishwanathan anand was the first grand
master in that country is absolutely
mind-blowing and probably nothing else
needs to be said to really understand
his greatness and legacy
in that now we're talking about
many of the world's best chess players
being indian of course growing up
i dreamt of becoming a world champion
even if i didn't
quite know what that involved
meant
but when i finally became world champion
[Music]
i could then realize that
there was some
i had done something historical
and i had broken through a barrier and
you know from now on
uh india would always have its first
world champion when magnus carlsen took
the torch from vishy anand i think it
was generally accepted that the time had
come and that magnus was maybe the best
chess player overall at least in all
facets of the game
magnus carlsen has been the world chess
champion since 2013.
born in 1990 his rise to become one of
the best players of the game
ever is nothing short of spectacular but
before carlson was known as a chess
prodigy he was just a five-year-old boy
who wasn't motivated by the lure of
prestigious titles he was motivated
initially by beating his older sister at
chess
after finally defeating his sister
soon carlson was playing against himself
reading chess books and being coached by
the top players in norway
by the age of 13 he was a grandmaster
by the age of 17 he was the norwegian
chess champion and by the age of 18 he
surpassed a 2 800 rating
the washington post dubbed him the
mozart of chess
after years of raising eyebrows and
earning praise carlson finally got his
chance at the world chess title in 2013.
his win over reigning champ vishyanan in
anan's home country of india was
heralded by former champ gary kasparov
as the start of a new era in chess
the young carlson who developed his game
in the age of super chess computers won
by three points
in 10 of 12 scheduled games
the two men reversed their roles in the
2014 world chess championship this time
carlson was the reigning champ and anand
was the challenger
according to the world championships
website the 2014 title match drew more
than 1 million viewers a day breaking
global audience records
they didn't have to play the schedule 12
games it took only 11 for carlson to
score the required six and a half points
needed to be declared the winner
objectively it's hard to say that magnus
carlson isn't the greatest player of all
time what makes him so great he's a
genius first he's obviously a genius
he's brilliant he perceives things on
another level he probably understands
higher level level principles that
haven't quite been articulated that
maybe can't even be put into words
magnus carlsen also has a photographic
memory but also natural ability natural
talent it's not only about like memory
but about um being able to focus to
concentrate to handle the pressure there
are so many things that uh make a player
a great player
the 2016 world chess championship pitted
carlson against russian grandmaster
sergey karjakin
who had been one of the youngest
grandmasters in history
after 12 games the score was tied
the match format
called for rapid chess to break the tie
carlson ultimately held on to his title
but the rapid playoff ending to the
world chess championship drew criticism
other respected players such as
four-time us champion yasser sirowan and
former world champion anatoly karpov
called it inappropriate
since there was already a world rapid
championship
it wouldn't be the last time a rapid
speed game would determine the title
in 2018 carlson's challenger was italian
american player fabiano caruana the
prize fund was 1 million euros the
format was 12 classical time control
games
with a rapid speed playoff in the event
of a time
every one of the 12 games ended in a
draw
it was the only time in world chess
championship history that all the
classical games ended in a draw
carlson won three consecutive rapid
speed games to retain his title
magnus carlsen's win in 2021 against jan
napon miyachi puts him in the elite club
of players with five or more world
titles which includes emmanuel alaska
mikhail bodwinick anatoly karpov gary
kasparov and viswanathan anand
since its beginning 1500 years ago
chess has reflected the people the
politics and the world in which we live
the game itself
is ever demanding and evolving
its champions determined and steadfast
in their quest for perfect play
there are so many reasons why chess is
appealing of course
i was captivated captivated by the game
from the start
as many players have been
i just loved it and that's really
what it's about loving the game
realizing how much fun it can be it's
sheer play
the challenge of it
overcoming difficulty
you be set with problems at the
chessboard and drawing upon your
resources
to find
just the right move
will bring a smile to just about
anyone's face
wild technology has provided a new
frontier for teaching analyzing and
training
it has also been instrumental in
expanding the fan base ensuring that the
game will continue to entertain and
challenge generations to come